whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up Nebraska
regulators who might ban beer pong and
the Belvedere school district to random
drug testing of middle school students
at a school in New Jersey parents do
have to consent but officials voted to
start drug and alcohol testing for
students as young as age 11 but there
can be only one nanny of the month in
this time it's new york state senator
carl kruger for cracking down on ipeds
you shouldn't be crossing streets and
endangering yourself and the lives of
others if you cross the street while
using an electronic device Kruger wants
to find you 100 bucks when people are
doing things at it detrimental to their
own well-being then government should
step in wonderful include overeating
because Krugers not the slimmest of
senators maybe government should lock up
his fridge for his own good check back
next month for more examples of
busybodies minded your own business